e aí assistir o canal quando você está
bem em é bom eu estou bom sabe por que
que eu estou praticamente ana maria
braga não é porque é nosso canal chegou
a 1 milhão de inscritos 1 1 milhão
galera no do 2º ano do ensino médio eu
cursava técnico em informática e você
sabe todo o curso quando acaba em fazer
umas horas de estágio a ligar eu ficava
lá e quando contaram não tinha nenhum
problema que eu tenho que consertar
ficar só pelo youtube e onde houve na
home do youtube um vídeo do vagas onde
em outro pc siqueira eu assisti o vídeo
pensei que achei mais com a posse de um
vídeo a gasóleo e papoula e pô vou criar
um canal eu pensei não vou fazer eu fiz
comecei fazendo um vlog até vergonha a
galera do colégio me parava para falar
assinado está fazendo um vídeo agora sei
que nossos 300 visualizações que é eu
parei de fazer depois de um tempo o fim
de novo com um colega meu não deu certo
eu parei de fazer também eu comecei a
fazer uns vídeos melhorzinho vem aí um
belo dia eu criei a paródia alô voto
reprovava 5 milhões de visualizações que
famosão da noite podia aí eu fiquei
feliz fiquei famoso que bonito na fita e
meu canal foi excluído meu canal foi
excluído é o cara sai da merda e vai pro
topo depois sai do topo vai para merda
aí meu irmão vou parar não dá certo se
até agora não deu certo desta vez de
excluir a que você secretário de
auxiliar de serviço de pedreiro você
auxiliar de venda de cremosinho a galera
me enchendo o saco como mensagem volta a
fazer vídeo volta a fazer 20 horas de
vídeo por favor volta a fazer vídeo tá
bom vou fazer vídeo voltei a fazer a
força dessas pequenas pessoas que
gostaram dos meus vídeos já foi tão
grande que eu cheguei a 100 inscritos
rápido foi enfático rápido 1536 três
meses 100 inscritos
aí juntou com o pacto com satanás
prontas subir também câmbio é cair na
coface e nem famoso fez pacto com
satanás projeção satanás é do povo e não
ajuda ninguém não deu não ajuda ninguém
lógica ajudam a dica pra quem quer ter
sucesso não faz parte com satanás está
não precisa de deus também a jogo não vi
que essa parada estava dando certo falou
mano eu vou sair de casa eu vou tentar
fazer as coisas sozinho vou tentar
viajar só vou fazer tudo tudo pra
mas é gente eu dei um tiro no escuro eu
não sabia se ia dar certo não sabe como
é que eu serei por bob posso ficar na
sua casa um dia pode aí eu fiquei um dia
na casa do bom ter mesmo foi dizendo que
ficar só um diz que só 180 dinheiro você
querer sair de repente você querer ser
independente e ter nada dependendo dos
outros é fácil e lá eu fiquei fazendo um
vídeo do youtube tentando fazer as
coisas da sé tentando fazer as coisas em
tarhuna aí saiu o meu primeiro dinheiro
no youtube eu fiquei feliz demais elogia
a mãe mãe sai o dinheiro do youtube e
está dando certo e dando certo r$630 meu
primeiro dinheiro no youtube é da casa
do blog tinha um quarto para alugar um
quartinho literalmente em um quartinho
12 cômodos só foi lá e deu dinheiro para
saber que tinha um ventilador e uma rede
era eu mudei pra essa casa com essa rede
esse indicador eu dormi pensando assim
meu deus fui acordar amanhã o que é que
eu vou comer eu ia na casa do bola meio
dia não só vim aqui serve como é que tal
bob tal aproveitava almoçava às vezes
nem estava lá eu sabia que não estava lá
mas eu ia a desculpa para ver meu amigo
mas achava que era chegado a fome ea
única refeição do dia é um amor às vezes
passava o dia todo sem comer
pego ele pediu verba de chegada de tite
está com fome mas como aqui às vezes
contar com muita muita forma dormia para
ver se passava na internet não tinha o
que comer mais e internet
quem disse ainda gravava em casa agitado
e atacar do leão e enviá-la cada
comentário bonito e ouvido ele pode
ficar um pedaço de pão que eu comi a
fome a passando minha mãe pedindo todo
dia eu voltar pra casa pra casa e volta
pra cá que eu nunca pude ter as coisas
nunca tive muita coisa
nunca tive nada tanto que até hoje não
me importo com roupa de marca não
importa com nada é que nenhum comentário
que eu vi no vídeo do bairro lá o
twitter que o canal bombando deve estar
ganhando muito dinheiro e só aparece no
meio disso eu não me importo nem possa
romper boas a roupa chama atenção se o
boné é bonito se o boné em pó
agora estou normal agora quando
conseguir as coisas desse certo só
coloquei na minha cabeça que eu queria
ter tudo aquilo que eu não conseguia ter
quando era criança tudo aquilo que meu
pai por me dar a minha mãe foi me dá eu
queria ter tanto eu comprei um play três
sem-teto televisão para jogar mal
completo para me dizer seu tempo essa
desgraça e meu sonho do meu sonho é
comprar um carro
eu queria muito e quando com pace car
não tivesse a média dos comentários a
ficou rico a usar a gente para comprar
um carro
a não ser que dudu eu só queria que
tivesse um comentário assim o time
moleque um dia passou fome comprou um
carro eu quero que vocês fiquem felizes
por mim quando as coisas derem certo pra
mim e fico feliz por favor fica feliz
comigo que [ __ ] mais de quase 160 vídeo
fazendo vocês felizes no dia que eu
ficar feliz você fica triste comigo
enfim eu queria agradecer de mágica tudo
isso toda essa minha vida em tão pouco
tempo eu só tenho 19 anos e sabe que eu
não sou velho ainda mais toda essa tudo
isso que me proporcionou foi você quem
sabe que foi você não sabe vocês a cada
comentário você está acabada light que
você deve ouvir tudo isso contribuiu
para hoje esse canal está com 1 milhão
de inscritos milhões muito milhões gente
pra [ __ ] imagina e um milhão de
pessoas
agora imagino a rua com um milhão de
pessoas até lá né é muito ruim e
periquito é muita gente eu queria
agradecer demais todos
não tenho não tenho como agradecer cada
um de vocês mas quando eu abrir esse
canal que eu vi um milhão de inscritos
eu fiquei muito feliz ligado mesmo não
ser obrigado então se você fez parte
dessa história se você ajudou a
construir se você ajudou a me fazer
feliz a fazer o meu pai feliz e minha
mãe feliz se você é feliz comigo por
essa conquista daquela clicar no gostar
eu vou ficar muito feliz mais pessoas
vão conhecer o canal e vai crescer mais
ainda
mas ainda fico feliz mas mas ainda fico
feliz mais ainda você fica feliz todo
mundo que eu queria muito que ele nasceu
feliz toda a venda maria braga fica
feliz todo mundo vai ficar feliz se você
é de fortaleza no ceará
o dia 20 de julho às sete da noite eu
vou tá fazendo um show de stand-up lá no
teatro do via sul no shopping via sul
onde é que comprei ingresso na
bilheteria do teatro a military na
bilheteria do teatro do via sul tá
valendo bilheteria do teatro via sul eu
queria um ingresso para o show do
windows on a 20 reais a meia entrada
belém é aquele mesmo esquema tira foto
com ingresso possam estar aqui vou dar
aquela curtida comentá-la e tal eu e dan
e é daí tá sabendo pediu que eu falei
pra você tem um amigo lá em fortaleza
lucas e o ney está participando da
promoção da garota
sim é um vídeo de dança o vídeo mais
votado ganha pode votar quantas vezes
quiser que ele ganhar ele vai ganhar uma
grana ele vai me dar um pouco dessa
grana é como fazer vou pegar essa grana
que ele me der eu vou contar todo de
ração e vou doar para uma casa que cuida
de animais beleza é o primeiro um link
na descrição do vídeo está no seu
facebook é abrir essa página aqui ontem
esse vídeo tem esse vídeo tem um vídeo
dele o lucas de honey fortaleza ceará 27
mil votos a primeira colocada com 157
mil votos lembrando que pode votar
quantas vezes quiser viu então aplicou
que digita ciclo de cozinha kiyota tarde
jeito que o código está aqui em cima
salvar voto nunca de honey pronto voltou
só e faria denovo quantas vezes eu
pudesse ele ganhar ele vai me dar a
grana eu pego essa grana consultor de
ração do pra casa e vocês vão ver vou
filmar tudo é nóis o corpo beleza lucas
de almeida o primeiro link na descrição
do vídeo volta lá e é nóis valeu nem
brigada e também a todo mundo que me
segue no instagram cuja foto lá e tal
sempre teve de novo lá toda essa galera
que me segue no twitter muito obrigado
todas as pessoas que curtirem a página
facebook todo mundo muito obrigado muito
obrigado por você assiste se viu até
aqui
valeu